(upbeat instrumental music)
- [Lukas ] There's something magical
about seeing the arrow
fly and hit the target.
Archery is difficult enough, you know, on the ground.
To be on the back of the horse
and to feel the wind in your face.
It’s a challenge, and I like challenge.
My name is Lukas Novotny, and I'm a bowyer
and horseback archer.
(guitar music)
What I do here is kind of
a history that's revived
in a sort of modern fashion.
I don't necessarily like to brag,
but I'm considered to be
one of the top archers.
I started making bows, uh, just as a hobby.
And then it kind of just drew me in.
You wouldn't be interested in a bow unless
you wanted to shoot it.
I mean, why would you want to make a bow
unless you wanted to pull that
string and let the arrow fly?
To come up with a bow that's perfect,
it's almost next to impossible I suppose,
but that's where the challenge lies.
It's like in horseback archery,
to get a perfect score on a run,
is, you know, that's a feat that
happens once in a while.
(neighs)
(tense instrumental music)
Here we have the Hungarian course.
It's scored by degree of difficulty.
Forward being difficult,
side being the easiest,
and the back being the most difficult
and being scored the highest.
Korean style is basically fairly simple.
It's a 150 meter track
with five targets spread
30 meters apart.
The Kabak is a Turkish style.
Dating back to ancient times.
It's a pole that's seven meters tall,
that's what we use as a standard.
At the top of it you have a target.
I'm not per se the best archer there is.
I don't know how it's
possible, how I've managed
to collect so many medals.
Maybe it's the saying of
the one man with one eye
is the king among the blind
or something (laughs).